ses marques au sol désigne les
emplacements où ont été ramassés les
deux des balles qui ont tué un jeune de
25 ans les faits se sont déroulés dans
cette rue du quartier l'épinette à
trinité dans la nuit de samedi à
dimanche non loin du domicile de la mère
de la victime
c'est l'incompréhension dans la famille
je ne comprends pas du tout mon côté
c'est un gars il est sans histoire c'est
vrai comment vous est bon il a eu des
petits soucis il a eu des petits soucis
mais c'est pas quelqu'un qui avait des
problèmes quand j'avais des petits
soucis il a déjà fait la prison à vie a
fait un petit séjour en prison vous
savez comme un petit peu comme tous les
jeunes mais ce n'était pas quelqu'un qui
avait des problèmes de là à se faire
assassiner quoi je me suis dit c'est
sûrement un braquage avait dit qu'on en
veut à ses objets à ce qu'il a sa moto
ou ses chaînes mais ne voilà-t-il pas
que quand on a trouvé il avait tout il
avait sa moto et ses chaînes donc c'est
vraiment à sa vie qu'on en voulait donc
c'est la violence pu respirer du en quoi
les voisins ne comprennent pas ce
déchaînement de violence à leur porte
d'autant plus que le quartier épinettes
n'a pas une mauvaise réputation
il est plutôt calme par cani parcours de
catherine baumont violence la sas au
point de vraiment un beau matin c'est
bon madame après sa terrible ça
surprenant
oui ça gâche cependant citer que camille
problème ici hier les gendarmes ont
ratissé tous les coins à la recherche
d'indicés supplémentaires
ils ont également effectué une enquête
de voisinage la section de recherches de
la gendarmerie devra déterminer les
circonstances et les causes de ce fait
divers tragique